hey guys today i'm going to show you uh
the things that i use to get the best
recording quality out of the fraps
screen recorder
uh first of all uh under the general tab
there's not much to see here it's just
details about the software itself um
under the fps tab you set your own
hotkey you choose what corner you want
the fps to be shown in
again not a whole lot down here unless
you want to save
certain benchmark stats
but under movies um i set mine sometimes
at 50 sometimes at 30 depending what
game i'm playing if i'm playing a less
graphics intensive game go ahead and set
it to 50 frames per second if not if
it's more graphics intensive and go
ahead and set it at 30 frames per second
and make sure you know what your video
capture hotkey is so that when you're in
the game all you have to do is press
that one
button
um for audio i chose it to record sound
and detect the best sound input which
will not necessarily be from your
speakers but it might be your system
sound which you can pick up also
uh so if you have music and game sounds
like a shooting game there might be
gunfire you can hear that much more
clearly if you
uh detect best sound input you can
choose to use windows input but that
might not always work so detect best
sound input is what i use
this to direct stream
and stereo because that's just the type
of sound that i have on the system
standard sound
um
and this is just a screen capture if you
want to take just one image just one
frame of the uh the game you're playing
then um i use f11 as in movies i would
start and end with f10 and screenshots
will start just one screenshot with f11
and it'll take a jpeg image or bitmap
image
uh really doesn't matter it could be a
png image or a tj image
i'll use bmp for now
and
that is that is how you use fraps now
when you're actually in a game i have a
video uh 1080p video that i uploaded
um it didn't it wasn't the best quality
ever but i do have a 1080p video up on
my site so go ahead and subscribe and
click on my name and you'll see the
fraps 1080p test under
my videos
um
that is an example uh i when i did that
video i only had the half version or the
uh you were limited to 30 seconds of
screen recording now i have a full
version of fraps so i am allowed to uh i
have unlimited screen recording time
um i use it to record
basically whatever game i might be
playing if i'm playing a game
i'll open up fraps and i might do some
benchmarking i might uh just look at see
the fps i'm getting friends per second
um i'm getting while playing and maybe i
want to record a video for keepsake
so um that's
that is what fraps is ladies and
gentlemen
um
i hope you enjoyed this video tutorial
try to upload this one in hd so go ahead
on the bottom right hand corner and
click on watching this in hd
wow
and um
yeah enjoy fraps oh um you know i'll
show you where to get for apps just in
case
you don't know already
this is firefox internet browser go
ahead and
uh go ahead and type in fraps
and
the first link was fraps.com it's really
simple
scroll down it'll tell you all about
different games you can record
using fraps
and click on the downloads tab
for
downloading the actual application these
are screenshots obviously from fraps
which you saw in my earlier part of the
video it's only 956 kilobytes it's
really small
um but then again
this is just the
free fraps version captures the fastest
with an nvidia geforce graphics card
and
sure enough
i have an nvidia geforce graphics card
where to go very good
maybe it's not gonna there we go nvidia
geforce 9200m
is my graphics card 512 megabits of ram
so there you go
download it here and if you want to buy
the full
or you want to be
crazy like me and torrent it
then
there's where you buy it you can use
visa mastercard paypal not a big deal
but you can still record up to 30
seconds of video and take screenshots
with the free version of fraps
so um and you can get the fps benchmark
etc so that is fraps for you and hope
you like this subscribe and more edgy
tutorials to come thanks peace
you